hallo freunde herzlich willkommen hier
zum video am mittwoch ich bin gerade in
new york weil mir aufgefallen dass ich
für den mittwoch gar kein video
produziert habe ich nie vergessen aber
doch so jedenfalls finde ich gerade in
new york noch bis übermorgen freitag an
fliegt zurück nach düsseldorf und von
dort nach berlin weil da noch was ist
allerdings habe ich jetzt gedacht bevor
ich gar nichts machte er in new york
heute hier für mittwoch mache ich ein
kurzes video wie hier durch stadt lockt
wir sehen da hinten kommt gerade die
sonne raus und es ist halt wirklich echt
so ein bisschen überdimensional alles
ist wirklich überall hochhäuser ihr seht
moment da hinten auch überall hochhäuser
dahin ist die new york stock exchange da
oben seht ihr das world trade center da
waren wir schon drauf das video seht ihr
dann irgendwann wenn nichts geschnitten
habe bald in der woche oder irgendwie so
jedenfalls habe ich schon richtig viel
erlebt ich bin noch besser richtig aktiv
ist der ist aber bei installation paar
sachen hoch bleiben allerdings möchte
ich bei instagram izzo ich könnte
theoretisch sieben fotos hochladen so
viel erleben wir aber ich möchte dir zu
verteilt über die nächsten tage wochen
hochladen weil ich habe einfach so viele
coole bilder so viel allein schon vor
dem buch von oben von world trade center
runter und so richtig krachen allerdings
habe ich nicht wirklich einfach das
heute hier können wir besser als das gar
nichts kommt lieber so dass ganz früher
passiert und so sieht das hier gerade
aus wie wir lang laufen also da ganz
hinten oben ist wirklich das world trade
center dass ich das nicht wirklich aus
allen sachen in wir aus eben die 1000
mehr als 1000 hoch oder so und wir das
sind ich und silke wir laufen jetzt
zurück zum hostel und ich muss jetzt mal
beenden weil ich hier oben schon bei
zwei minuten bin ich weiß nicht ob ich
das noch unter kurzen werde aber